Ginger armor is the daily moisturizing
mineral sunscreen perfect for any skin
type chemical sunscreens can cause
health issues including skin irritation
and stinging eyes but with ginger armors
ingredients from plants and minerals and
it being scent free and rubbing on
invisibly in seconds it's the best get
15 off with code Pacman using the link
below Ukrainian President Vladimir
zelenski made a sort of last minute at
least as far as it was announced visit
to Washington DC yesterday which
included an address to Congress a an
opportunity that not many foreign
leaders get and we will talk about that
in a little bit the speech that
zielinski delivered to Congress about
the help that the U.S has been providing
to Ukraine in its defensive War due to
the invasion of Ukraine by Russia and
Vladimir Putin was a good speech it was
a powerful speech and also the entire
event had a pretty weird feeling to it
and I think I know what the weirdness
was and I'm going to talk about that in
a moment much fanfare and we're going to
get to all aspects of this but a big
Standing Ovation to kick it all off
and what we're watching here if you're
watching today rather than listening is
zelenski entering too much Applause and
a standing ovation and the greetings of
so many different people there's Senator
Patrick Leahy and you see Charles
Schumer the senator uh and all sorts of
different people
um zielinski wearing his typical
green I don't I don't know that I want
to editorialize the shade of green but
it is not the best shade not that we
really care about that it's just a weird
color
and here he greets uh vice president
Kamala Harris and then the Speaker of
the House outgoing Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi and he delivers a speech
and many Applause lines in the speech
including reminding the world and the
United States that Ukraine is not out of
this thing against
All Odds and doom and gloom
cenarius Ukraine didn't fall
Ukraine is alive
and Kicking
and another Standing Ovation there and
of course it is great that Ukraine has
been able to resist what some
characterized and handicapped as an easy
win for Russia when this started months
and months and closing in on a year ago
uh that is an absolutely great thing we
now get into the part that I believe was
the element of weirdness which is that
there was a feeling of this that it was
sort of okay we're gonna give you the
money new Aid package around 2 billion
including Patriot missiles we're gonna
do it but you've got to come here and
you've got to really thank us and you've
got to act extremely
solicitously towards us and that was
absolutely a big element of this speech
I'm glad to shred that President Biden
supported our peace initiative today
each of you ladies and gentlemen can't
assist in the implementation to ensure
that Americans leadership remains solid
by camera
and bipartisan
thank you
and of course it is not actually
completely bipartisan and that's part of
what's interesting about this there are
people there are Republicans who are
sort of
soft supporters of the U.S helping
Ukraine and then there are people like
Matt Gates and Lauren bobert who
um are flat out just against American
help of Ukraine and they've sped into
the house chamber at the last minute and
sat there looking visibly bored never
clapping as a deliberate show of how
against this they are uh zelenski
assuring and reminding everyone in the
chamber that the money we are sending to
Ukraine is not charity it is part of uh
the goal shared goal of Global Security
and democracy Financial financial
assistance is also critically important
and I would like to thank you thank you
very much thank you for both Financial
packages you have already provided us
with and the ones you may be willing to
decide on your money is not charity
right it's and investment in the global
security and democracy that we handle in
the most responsible way
[Applause]
Financial financials okay and um this
ultimately led to uh a Ukrainian flag
actually being unfurled on the floor of
the house let this flag stay with you
lettuce and gentlemen this flag is a
symbol of our victory in this war
We Stand we fight and we will win
because we are united Ukraine America
and the entire free world
okay so now what's happening is zelenski
is unfurling a Ukrainian flag which is
now being held up by Nancy Pelosi
um and vice president Kamala Harris
and then similarly you might see off to
the right of the screen that there is an
American flag in a triangle shape and
then that was handed to zelenski and off
he went with his American flag
and now this is the end of the speech
and we see zelenski leaving with his
American flag that was handed to him so
listen my feelings on this are very
mixed
of course I support Ukraine and of
course I believe that it is in the
interests of the United States and our
allies to beat back The Invasion by
Russia Putin's a lunatic authoritarian I
mean listen I've got a decade of
commentary on this there is absolutely
no question there
this entire visit
extraordinarily heavy on the theatrics
which I I feel repelled by the theatrics
to a great degree because it is such a
stage managed event
but public opinion particularly Global
public opinion depends on exactly that
stage management and so while I
personally find it off-putting as
someone who follows this stuff all the
time I have to be open to the idea that
for people who are busy working in
fields that are not political media
their opinion about what should happen
may actually be shaped by events like
this and maybe they want to see zelenski
come and grovel a little bit maybe
that's what they need in order to be
okay with or to continue seeing support
of Ukraine as a worthy cause now the
history of speech is like this to
Congress
during conflicts by world leaders of
other countries it's not the longest
list in the world
and we know of course of Winston
Churchill's address to Congress during
World War II as the prime minister of
the UK we know about
lekwaleza's address to Congress during
the Cold War as president of Poland we
know about Nelson Mandela's address to
Congress during the apartheid era
Mandela the first president of South
Africa and we have uh I may be missing a
couple but we have uh hovel's address to
Congress during the Velvet Revolution
the last the last and final president of
Czechoslovakia how does this compare
how does the situation in Ukraine
compare
not only on the facts but in terms of
its relation to the United States I
don't know that I have that answer and
it may require looking back from some
Future Point uh to really fully
understand that but a powerful speech
heavy on theatrics that I think was sort
of determined to be necessary
to continue
justifying to some degree in the court
of public opinion the support to Ukraine
that the United States continues to give
support which I widely am in favor of
while recognizing that those are dollars
for what is effectively speaking a proxy
war against Russia doesn't make it bad
uh in fact it's the right side this was
a war of aggression by Russia but much
more complicated than any simple
explanation under oath
Fox News propaganda Sean Hannity admits
he doesn't believe Donald Trump's fraud
claims about 2020 and yet
he widely promoted them and hosted
guests uncritically who also promoted
those very same sorts of claims a very
interesting article from The New York
Times in testimony Hannity and other Fox
employees said they doubted Trump's
fraud claims Wednesday lawyers for
Dominion voting systems shared some of
the strongest evidence yet that some Fox
employees knew what they broadcast about
the claims was false the articles by
Jeremy Peters we will link to it in the
description to the YouTube video
November 30th Sean of 2020. Sean Hannity
hosted Sydney Powell on his show as she
had in many other interviews Fox and
elsewhere she spun wild conspiracy
theories about what she said was
corruption all across the country in
countless districts in a plot to steal
re-election from the president Donald
Trump
at the center of the plot were machines
from Dominion voting systems which
Powell claimed ran an algorithm
sometimes they called it a logarithm
that switched votes from Trump to Biden
Hannity interrupted her with a gentle
question that had been circulating
uh among election deniers despite a lack
of supporting proof why were Democrats
silencing whistleblowers who could prove
the fraud did Hannity believe any of
this quote I did not believe it for one
second
now if you watched Hannity's TV show you
wouldn't have heard him say that Hannity
gave that answer under oath in a
deposition in Dominion's 1.6 billion
dollar defamation lawsuit against Fox
News according to info disclosed
yesterday
Hannity's disclosure along with others
that emerged about what Fox News
Executives and hosts really believed
became one of the loudest megaphones for
lie as their Network became one of the
loudest megaphones for lies about the
election this is the strongest evidence
yet that fox employees knew what they
were broadcasting was false this is not
a shock this is not a shock Hannity is
an amoral propagandist profiteer no
doubt about it but he is not so stupid
that he believed this nonsense and in
fact the totality of the text messages
that we now know Sean Hannity sent to
people like Mark Meadows and others and
this deposition under oath tells us
they were knowingly spreading
misinformation it doesn't make it any
better okay if you thought Hannity was
that stupid he's not that stupid
but it tells us he knew he was spreading
lies it's almost an even worse case for
them they weren't just gullible idiots
they were knowingly spreading lies and
disinformation and of course we know
that when push comes to shove they go
for it's not news It's Entertainment
Tucker Carlson Fox News lawyer said
Tucker Carlson is an Entertainer it's
not news the things he says are laced
with Hyperbole and exaggeration and
titillating language they're not to
believe be believed literally but in
reality it's not even really
entertainment because it's not
entertaining it's sort of BS and lies
it's a BS Factory that they pump out not
just for profit yes profit is part of it
but it's also to maintain access to
people in power Hannity we now know how
to relationship with Trump to the extent
that Trump has friends and for Trump a
friend means someone who's useful to me
until they turn against me okay fine but
that's the definition Hannity would hang
out with Trump people be on uh with
Trump's plane and all this different
stuff
it was to maintain access as much as it
was for profitability now in a
well-functioning educated democracy
where people are educated in media
literacy Etc
people like Hannity wouldn't have
careers not because they're kicked off
of the air I'm not suggesting anyone
kicked them off the air but I'm saying
no one would watch it
if we had an educated informed democracy
Now ultimately I really don't care if
they claim now to have privately doubted
the things Trump was spreading they
publicly supported it and they are part
of why there was a public willing to go
and do what they did on January 6th will
there be any consequences for this
probably not
tomorrow Friday is the day
one day membership special last discount
of the year last opportunity to
participate in the membership special
for the year your first month payment is
going to be donated and doubled we are
working with a charity who I will name
tomorrow because they told us it's a
problem for them if we name them in
advance
we're entering into a marketing
agreement and it can be a problem for
them as a 501c3 but many of you I know
know which charity it is one of the most
effective ways to actually help people
around the world is to give them cash
something like 98 of donated funds get
to people when you just send them cash
and let them figure out what they need
so tomorrow if you're on my mailing list
you're going to get an email and it's
going to tell you how to sign up at a
discount your first month's payment
we're going to donate and then we're
going to double it up to the first
fifteen thousand dollars really great
opportunity to both get a membership
help us by getting access to the bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad and we
are helping other people so get on my
mailing list at davidpackman.com
tomorrow morning maybe late morning
maybe early afternoon you'll get an
email telling you how to Avail yourself
of this fantastic special
one of our sponsors today is ginger
armor the daily moisturizing mineral
sunscreen that's good for you and the
planet I've talked before about why I
only use mineral sunscreen instead of
chemical sunscreen I want a physical
barrier rather than chemicals absorbed
by the skin Ginger armor is an everyday
sunscreen moisturizer lip balm combo
that goes on lightweight unseen and
unscented perfect for all skin types
with powerful SPF 50 plus protection
rubs on invisibly in seconds no smell
feels good after shaving to stay
moisturized all day and the super
portable design is really good on the go
and it's made with 21 simple Earth
friendly ingredients from plants and
minerals unlike the chemical sunscreens
which can irritate skin worsen certain
conditions sting eyes Ginger armor is my
go-to for daily skin protection and
moisturizing even in Winter I know
you'll love it too it's also more
affordable than other mineral sunscreens
and it is a small business supporting
the David packman show go to
gingerarmor.com and use code Pacman for
15 off the link is below well it begins
Donald Trump paid zero in taxes in 2020
claimed a 5 million dollar refund and
the big picture of Trump's taxes that
has come out based on a report we have
we don't yet have the tax returns but we
have a report about the tax returns from
the house Ways and Means Committee is
just about everything that we suspected
everything that we suspected and we're
going to talk about it so let's start
with the big picture data let's look at
Trump's income taxable income and taxes
paid over the last six years in 2015
Trump reported an income loss of nearly
32 million dollars paid had zero taxable
income and paid 640 000 in taxes in 2016
Trump says he lost 31 million dollars
had zero taxable income and paid 750
dollars not 750 000. 750 dollars in
taxes 2017 Trump claimed negative income
of 13 million dollars paid 750 dollars
in taxes in 2018 Trump claimed a taxable
income of 23 million and paid about a
million in taxes on that 2019 Trump
claimed about 3 million dollars in
taxable income and paid a little over a
hundred K in taxes and then in 2020
Trump reported a loss of nearly five
million dollars and paid
0.0 in federal taxes claiming a refund
of
5.47 million dollars there's a good CNBC
write-up called read how much Trump paid
or didn't pay in taxes each year uh it
outlines the numbers that I just
mentioned with a number of other
elements including
um that the tax returns we're ultimately
going to get are redacted and it may
actually still be difficult to figure
out
how Trump got to these negative income
claims Etc
um the most important thing that I think
is is worth mentioning here is that most
of this stuff is almost certainly legal
and what we're really getting to here is
the failure of the IRS despite all these
claims that the IRS is predatory and
they've got all these armed people which
they really did they have very few armed
people and it's not a big deal that some
of the people are armed despite all the
claims about the IRS the IRS really has
failed us not even auditing Trump in his
required automatic audit that presidents
get
until they caught wind that Richard Neal
in the house Ways and Means Committee
was trying to obtain these tax returns
then they said oh we'd better do that
audit on Trump which we were supposed to
have done already for several years so a
few different aspects to this is it
possible that Trump's taxes will expose
crimes absolutely they look like they
would be along the fraud lines stating
different asset values for the same
assets depending on whether he's trying
to avoid property taxes or personal
taxes versus get a loan using those
assets as collateral we already suspect
and in fact we know based on what
happened the ruling with Trump's uh
business of 17 guilty counts I guess it
was two weeks ago we already know that
that was done at the business level
almost certainly being done at the
personal level the taxes will help to
build that case are there potential
National Security issues as a result of
some of the people Trump is in League
with absolutely the tax returns could
very well expose that but what's really
important to understand is that Trump's
not the only rich guy using the tax code
in this way and widely speaking avoiding
IRS scrutiny that would be appropriate
for the uh relaxed application of the
tax law that Trump and people like him
use so this is a story about Trump but
it's also a story about the tax code and
a story about the IRS now one question
that you may have is how do you go
negative close to a hundred million
dollars over five years in income and
yet still live the lifestyle that Trump
lives with day-to-day expenses being so
lavish and expensive the private plane
all these different things if you lose
30 million in a year how do you also
have a private plan and all this stuff
the answer is that you are asset Rich
you are asset rich and you can also we
don't fully know because we don't have
the full tax returns yet but you can
borrow against the assets to have money
with which to live that lavish lifestyle
and again it is not unique to Trump
if anything good will come of this it's
that the Trump tax returns will expose
the mechanisms that many rich people use
in order to live lavish Lifestyles but
pay almost no taxes or in some cases no
cases no taxes at all you tell lenders
that your assets are appreciating
dramatically and then they'll give you
girthy huge loans against those assets
which you can then use to live your
lavish lifestyle you tell the IRS these
very same assets are worth nothing I
lost money on these assets let me take a
loss on them giving a tax refund that's
very generally speaking the name of the
game then you live off of the loans you
use the lot the lies to the IRS to claim
a negative income while you're actually
making millions and then you get a tax
refund as well now if uh Donald Trump is
actually as rich as he claims to be
these tax returns don't really make it
look like Trump is super rich
if Trump is really as rich as he claims
to be there's almost certain certainly
criminal level of Fraud and avoidance
that's going on here
um the other possibility is Trump isn't
actually nearly as rich as he claims to
be and we may or may not find that out
the reason Trump clearly fought so hard
to keep his financial records from
becoming public is because he seems to
be the fraud he seems to be not not
quite or nearly as rich as he claims to
be
doing really sketchy stuff with asset
values we've given you the full list
before but the really important takeaway
is it's not just Trump doing this stuff
and there's a question as to whether
it's the tax code or the enforcement
that's the problem and I want to talk
about the IRS component next one of the
major Revelations of the Trump tax
returns has nothing to do with Donald
Trump it actually has to do with the IRS
and there's a really good article in The
Daily Beast by Sean Wu
called we haven't seen Trump's taxes yet
but it's clear the IRS failed America
the IRS is required to conduct audits of
the President and Vice President while
they're in office but Trump apparently
got a pass we'll link to this article in
the description for the YouTube video
that we're going to put up but let's
talk about the big picture here
the IRS didn't even audit the president
who's supposed to be audited as a matter
of of automatic principle it's supposed
to be mandatory audit of the president
and as you zoom out you find yet another
one of these projection
hypocrisy logic pretzels that the right
often gets itself into
they complain about the IRS the IRS is
too big
and the IRS is cracking down too much on
the wealthy and the IRS is politically
biased and going after the conservatives
even though we know that that's actually
that that was an Obama era pseudo
Scandal which has been completely
debunked and they say we're for Law and
Order
and yet what we see is they never want
to fully fund the IRS and they seem
perfectly happier at least indifferent
to the fact that the IRS isn't even
really doing the minimum it's almost
like they don't really want rich people
and in particular Rich conservatives to
have to follow the rules
predating this specific incident think
back
the IRS has a history of discrimination
and unequal enforcement especially
against marginalized communities and
small business owners we could also look
at the ongoing issues with the irs's
outdated and error-prone systems which
for average taxpayers just make it
really difficult to get your taxes done
people often end up going to paid
Services even though there are often
free services available depending on
your income the confusion and the
frustration that the IRS continues to
put taxpayers through average taxpayers
combined with the tax software Lobby
which is very strong create a situation
where for many of the average taxpayers
with average incomes it's both more
expensive and more complicated and
frustrating and convoluted to file our
taxes than it has to be while meanwhile
the very rich and the privileged take
advantage of all sorts of different
mechanisms to often end up paying a
dramatically lower effective tax rate
than people with significantly lower
incomes that's a failure of the IRS and
of the elected officials that dictate
tax policy and manage the IRS and then
when you think about what is this really
done
the IRS has played a major role in
enabling corruption and abuses of Power
by the wealthy and Powerful by turning a
blind eye to what is and again we tax
avoidance and evasion of I believe
avoidance is legal whereas evasion is
not there's a gray area there in terms
of the spirit of of a lot of these laws
if not the letter by turning apply a
blind eye to it and failing to even
adequately audit and investigate
high-income people in corporations they
are allowing the wealthy to buy their
way out of paying their fair share above
and beyond what the tax code is even
trying to achieve so this is the type of
stuff that erodes trust and faith in
government and meanwhile they want to
tell you oh Biden wants to double the
size of the IRS and arm everyone when
the truth is that there's 55 000 IRS
people expected to retire over the next
10 years 55
000 of the new hires are just to replace
people that are retiring that just gets
us to where we are now in in terms of
their arming the IRS the IRS has a small
law enforcement division so does Amtrak
so does the MTA in New York City it's
not really a big deal it's not actually
an authoritarian police state Crackdown
they want to focus on that when the
truth is the IRS is dramatically
undersized and underpowered and that's
really what we're learning from the
Trump tax return story
an insanely sweaty Donald Trump has
delivered a visibly confused statement
on immigration I guess this is his
campaign you know for a guy who said
Biden's a loser for running a campaign
from his basement even though Trump lost
to the guy running a campaign from his
basement Trump now I guess this is his
campaign putting to get filming in a
very hot room where he's sweating and
talking about issues he doesn't
understand here is Trump's latest
statement put out yesterday about
immigration
and that that volume is out
humiliatingly low here we go let's let's
start it over
far more illegal immigrants have entered
the United States in the last two years
that at any time in American history and
by a massive margin now if that is true
what Trump is talking about is
we've caught more people
now if you're catching them aren't you
doing a good job as far as Trump is
concerned
confusing we've never seen anything like
it our country is under Invasion nothing
has dramatically changed on immigration
since Trump left and Biden came in other
than there was a temporary slowdown on
movement of people due to the pandemic
and that has eased but policy wise
almost nothing has changed days ago 16
000 illegal aliens were encountered
crossing the border in a single 48-hour
period Now understand by the way the
jump Cuts because Trump can't string
together more than a sentence at a time
or bizarre remember
what Trump means by encounter is
apprehended
apprehended that sounds like the border
patrol under Biden is doing a pretty
good job by Trump's own standards a
colossal migrant Caravan recently poured
across the Rio Grande and into the
streets of El Paso Texas and the people
and the police didn't know what to do
about it it is truly a massive Invasion
any form of amnesty now would be a
catastrophe it rewards Joe Biden's
lawlessness and it rewards the criminal
cartels and it rewards everyone who has
broken the laws of our nation and again
the first priority on amnesty is people
who have not broken the law kids
individuals who were brought here when
they were legally minors were talking
about DACA it's low-hanging fruit we
should deal with it we could deal with
it they don't want to do it because
they've never done anything to our
country like they're doing right now our
country is being poisoned remember our
border is not open because by the way
dehumanizing language people are
poisoning the country they are so filthy
that they are it's a poison of
insufficient resources or
legal authorities our border is opened
because Joe Biden has ordered it to be
open understand that there is no such
policy that Biden has enacted because
Biden has broken the law and torn it
into shreds he has shredded our system
and he's destroying our country Biden
inherited a Flawless deportation system
that was working like never before in
our history we never did so well on the
border as we were doing just a short
time ago now understand that the
deportation system Trump's talking about
is the use of title 42 to more quickly
Deport people that is on the basis of
covid being a global emergency Trump
wants you to believe covet wasn't really
a big deal and and all these red State
Governors were right to do nothing about
it but it was also such a big deal that
you needed an expedited removal process
for migrants wait how can both be true
was covet an emergency or was it not
Trump Administration giving Biden more
resources will simply translate to even
more releases because that's really what
they have in mind all right so none of
this is true and again for a guy who
ridiculed Biden for campaigning from his
basement Trump's campaign in the five to
six weeks since he announced has been to
sit in a hot room and record sweaty
videos it doesn't sound particularly
good and by the way Biden's polling was
much better than Trump seems to be right
now we'll have this clip on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show wild and wacky stuff
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
Garrett Brew Hogg who's a PhD candidate
at the University of Rochester working
at the laboratory of laser energetics
the largest university laser lab in one
of the only places in the world that can
do laser driven Fusion experiments
Garrett really great having you on today
I appreciate it
yeah happy to come on David so I want to
talk about this recent uh breakthrough
that's made a lot of news in the field
of Fusion Energy before we even get to
that let's maybe develop an
understanding of what we mean when we
say Fusion Energy I think for a lot of
people it's it's sort of straightforward
to understand okay you can take
something like coal and you burn it and
then you can use that heat to do
different things I think many people can
understand that or you burn gasoline in
your car when we're talking about Fusion
Energy what exactly is it what are we
talking about what's the mechanism
yeah so Fusion is one of the two primary
forms of nuclear energy that we can uh
acquire right now what we do it all over
the world in fact what's keeping my
lights on right now is uh fission where
we split very heavy things like uranium
and utilize the heat to boil water turn
a turbine and make power to power our
homes Fusion is what powers the sun uh
it's also what powers our largest
thermonuclear weapons it's where we take
very small atoms like helium and force
them together that generates an enormous
amount of energy and we have never been
able to do a controlled sustained Fusion
chain reaction on Earth without a
thermonuclear weapon until last week or
two weeks ago so
Fusion is the coming together of atoms
in order to produce uh is it is it
accurate to say to produce heat
uh it produces several forms of energy
but everything will eventually just get
converted to heat to boil water or heat
up gases or something like that it's
it's kind of the the old adage that no
matter what Humanity does we eventually
boil water right okay so in other words
fission is the separation of atoms
whereas Fusion is the combination that's
that's sort of the fundamental
difference we're talking about
yes so the Breakthrough which you
alluded to at Lawrence Livermore
National Lab in California it's being
described as a huge advancement towards
nuclear fusion what what exactly is it
that happened
yeah so it is a really big scientific
achievement it's a huge advancement it's
been the the goal essentially ever since
we discovered Fusion to uh get a fusion
Chain Reaction uh in the laboratory so
Humanity has generated Fusion chain
reactions we did it first in the 1950s
with the ID Mike thermonuclear weapon
and now it's some of our scariest
weapons but that is not useful that is
just a capability we have we want Fusion
on a small scale controllable so that we
can make clean sources of power and that
has been very very challenging to do and
what Lawrence Livermore National Labs
did was they generated a self-sustained
fusion chain reaction in the lab no
nuclear bombs no gigantic destruction
everything was controlled and done and
is repeatable and that has never been
done before so it is it is a huge
advancement it's kind of like a Kitty
Hawk moment the airplane is finally
taken off what would it look like to use
this technology to generate the energy
that humans use for day-to-day lives
what what would do we know what a fusion
power plant would look like
yeah there's a lot of different designs
using lots of different Technologies
there's a there's a huge plethora of
ideas for how to use Fusion once you can
get ignition which is what Livermore did
um for for your average person it's
going to look just like a fission power
plant it'll be just a big chunk of
concrete that will make an enormous
amount of power for the amount of land
it takes up there will be no CO2 and you
might see some clouds coming out from
the cooling water and that would be
about it so with with our traditional is
is it fair to say that our traditional
nuclear power plants these are what we
would call fission nuclear power plants
attack here they split atoms and thus
they do fission at those plants one of
the concerns that exists is what do you
do with the spent Fuel and how long it
lasts Etc now I've said before I think
that those who are basing their opinion
on nuclear fission based on 40 year old
plants are probably not accurately
assessing them based on what modern
plants would look like but putting that
issue aside for a second you still have
this issue of the spent fuel in a fusion
plant
what are the source materials and what's
left over after the fact
so the source material is some special
forms of hydrogen but it's something
that's in the glass of water I'm
drinking from right now called deuterium
so that's heavy hydrogen it's very
common it's not a big deal it's used in
all sorts of applications primarily
nuclear but even in medical tracers and
we have effectively an infinite supply
of it
it would you know the sun will be long
burnt out before we ever burn through
the deuterium Supply uh the type of
fusion that Lawrence Livermore did which
is the quote-unquote easiest Fusion is
still very very hard it's called
deuterium tritium so the other input is
a special type of radioactive hydrogen
called tritium we have to breed that via
lithium so from the perspective of an
outside Observer ignoring all the
science the plant will eat deuterium
which we just get from water and a small
amount of lithium now we we get concerns
about lithium supplies because of
electric cars and things like that but
we're talking like a hundred kilos of
lithium a year for a power plant that
could power a major city it's not a it's
not a major concern it's just like with
fission where the total amount of
material going in and out is just
minuscule there is no direct nuclear
waste there's no spent fuel from Fusion
um it just makes helium but it also
makes an absurd number of neutrons which
is a type of radiation and it will make
the inside of the reactor radioactive
there is no way to get around
radioactive waste anytime we do any kind
of nuclear activities including medicine
every hospital generates a large flux of
radioactive waste but it's a benefit
it's cancer treatment and therapies and
all this good stuff
and we know how to handle the waste from
uh these sorts of systems Fusion would
not generate the very long-lived spent
fuel as you pointed out we can handle
the spent fuel from fission but ignoring
that Fusion won't generate it we're
talking things more like a hundred years
of radioactive Lifetime and there's
ideas for how to even shorten that
um so that that is one of the big
advantages that people point to with
Fusion what are the
um risks of this technology applied as a
power plant for example to power a city
as you mentioned what what can go wrong
and if something goes wrong what happens
um in some sort of kind of absurd worst
case scenario you could have radioactive
material released to the environment it
would be small it would be the impact
would be very low the general issues
would be things to people at the plant
very similar to what's happened with
fission failures you if you worked at
the plant you'd be worried you might
have to fight a fire or something like
that often Fusion is fusion power plants
are envisioned to use very interesting
weird coolant so you imagine like
flowing super hot liquid lithium I'm not
so afraid of the radiation I'm afraid of
flowing liquid lithium getting in the
air because that will make a very nasty
fire
um but these are all you know the fusion
is going to be regulated just like
fission it's going to be very very
tightly controlled and everyone takes
this job very seriously as to how it
would be put together I wouldn't I I
would be more than willing just like I'm
willing to live right now right next to
a fission plant I wouldn't have any
concern living next to a fusion plant
right now if my understanding is still
accurate it takes somewhere between six
and ten years to get a new nuclear
fission plant up and running
what is the timeline and maybe it's hard
to say because we don't yet exactly know
what these would look like but is there
a different timeline for Fusion Energy
plants
there is hope that it could be sped up
but I honestly think the sort of things
that would speed up a fusion plant
construction will speed up fission
construction as well a lot of the issues
that we see with fission come down to
just some of the dumbest stuff like
pouring concrete and laying steel uh
Fusion requires a lot more complex
equipment too so it's going to be many
iterations of learning how to build
these power plants before we ever get
good at it
um it's not something I would expect to
see even even if everything was ready to
go tomorrow I wouldn't expect to see
power plants just going up left and
right without massive honestly
government support you have to look at
how places like France did their large
fission build outs you just have to
throw tons of money and Personnel at it
when you
um look at something like or let me put
it a different way when you talk about
this being difficult Fusion being
difficult what does that really mean in
the sense that as an outsider in my mind
it seems to me that once you figure out
what you need in terms of equipment and
you do it you do it now you can
replicate it is is there some chance to
it where you can do the exact same thing
and it only works some of the time at
this point
so we are on
um we have just got an ignition
at Lawrence Livermore arguably we got it
last year but we don't need to quibble
about all of that what it is is we're
there now but we're only just barely
getting there
and if you've ever played around with
something like like doing a science
experiment
um where you're just figuring it out
there's often mistakes and issues and it
takes you just kind of have to do
something over and over and over again
to learn how to do it better but by
difficult what I'm actually getting at
with Fusion is that the conditions
needed to make a fusion reaction happen
are very very very hard to reach and the
equipment required is very expensive and
complicated when we're comparing to
other sources of power like let's just
take vision for an easy example you take
a rock that we dig out of the ground
turn it into a metal stick it into water
and the water gets hot for Fusion we
have to have some of the largest lasers
in the world
hitting little tiny targets or massive
incredible magnets that there's just
nothing to compare to now that's not to
say we can't get good at that I mean jet
engines used to be one of the most
complicated and incredible things on the
planet that only militaries could afford
and now all of us can ride on a jet
aircraft the aircraft themselves used to
be something that almost no one could
build
but it's we are at the like I said we're
kind of at the Kitty Hawk moment we just
got things to go we're not getting 747s
tomorrow
if we
zoom out a little bit
the feeling seems to be growing that in
even as little as 50 years we're going
to look at the status quo of cars
driving around burning gasoline pulling
oil out of the ground burning coal this
this is going to seem crazy for lack of
a better term right I mean it seems as
though what we are the the forms of
energy we're using now are going to seem
almost primitive compared to what is
apparently on the horizon is that the
right assessment
yeah I would say so I mean we already
have a lot of options that make uh
what's currently powering most of the
world look primitive right we can we can
already utilize things like uh nuclear
fission we have you know good
photovoltaics stuff like that this the
Sci-Fi technologies here and it's only
getting better
when people say that fusion power
is the Holy Grail of clean energy
this is based on emissions specifically
or are there other aspects to this too
the claim the reasoning behind that and
I'm not all I'm not entirely sold on
that statement okay um I I think it's
I've heard it I've heard it plenty of
times I think it comes from a kind of
Science Fiction optimism around fusion
um and and a lack of understanding or
maybe not a lack but a nativity over
some of the other sources
Fusion is emissions free this the fuel
supply is effectively infinite like I
said it's it doesn't matter there's so
much it's it we don't even need to worry
about it
um
and those are the big benefits on top of
the lower radioactive uh waste inventory
but what I just described is basically
Advanced fission as well
and so I think that's kind of where that
it doesn't always click it's this idea
that if we got to Fusion then all our
problems are solved but that's not
really true one like I said it's going
to be hard to get these things out and
cheap and effective and reliable
but we have options now that can reach a
lot of those goals Fusion in my mind is
more of filling in this uh large
portfolio of various energy options each
of them have benefits uh and you know
drawbacks
and it's not just this science fiction
Utopia
last thing I want to ask you what's the
next step is it just to repeat this very
same thing that happened or or is there
some clear Advanced Next Step that we go
to
so the immediate next step is to repeat
and get more Fusion yield we think due
to how ignition works it's like striking
a match once you can get the match to
strike you can get more and more fire we
think we can get a lot more Fusion out
of the Livermore facility so they're
going to work on that as hard as
possible but there's already designs for
how to build the next laser facilities
uh to push this forward and there's
other Fusion Concepts that can that are
being worked on other reactors but
everyone can use the fact that we lit
the match to study how that matches lit
right and to to build these next step
machines I expect we'll see many
machines reaching ignition in the next
10 years and then we can really start to
evaluate what's the best way to move
forward for power
propulsion
which is a whole other aspect to it also
yeah that that uh relates to the idea of
going to Mars and connects with so many
other things that are going on
fascinating stuff we've been speaking
with Garrett Brew Hogg who's a PhD
candidate at the University of Rochester
Garrett really appreciate your time
today thank you
yeah thank you so much
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
I think you're gonna like this did Kerry
Lake hire the worst lawyers in the world
for this completely bogus attempt to
steal the Arizona gubernatorial election
which she of course lost before I show
you the lawyers remember what Carrie
Lake said yesterday we looked at this
clip yesterday where she was talking
about hiring lawyers our true Patriots
we had attorneys who did walk away
because the left is threatening them
with their ability to make a living and
practice law and some of our attorneys
said look I got mouths to feed I can't
do this case I don't want to be
sanctioned so I I really love I I got to
a point where I said I'll take anybody
we'll take Better Call Saul to come on
in here yeah she'll quite literally
allow any lawyer to represent her so
let's get to the chaos significant
difficulties yesterday for Kerry Lake's
legal team they had an issue with their
witness list and then they forgot they
removed a witness and then they try to
call that witness and the judge is like
you told us you weren't calling this
person look at the level of confusion
among these lawyers not exactly legal
geniuses what happened
he's saying that he's not on the list
oh this is the best
so they're shuffling through their
paperwork now
where is that list who's on the list
they're saying he's not on the left
the list I'm looking at your honor does
show Aerosmith designated a witness if
your honor wants to give me a few
minutes I can go through my emails and
uh if you get what I was what the court
was given and I don't know that we
provided that list I think
we also I think there was an email
communication from uh plaintiff's
council not exactly Clarence Darrow as
you can imagine continued problems then
uh where they now
um it just it just it's so bad look at
this that she works with Betty in
getting records from Maricopa County
okay in response to to foyer request
your honor and you've also told me that
this was disclosed previously yes I am
your honor yes when was it disclosed to
oh I'm sorry your honored this last week
has been like four months
and I I if if you want your honor is
going to take me a good 45 minutes look
for our disclosures you're like we
stopped one second you're an officer of
the court I'm just asking for your word
if you tell me it was with it I'm
telling you it was disclosure you're
telling me within the last week yes
you're on right this morning something
like that your honor that I have created
on two separate occasions at their
request that I give them access to all
of our records via a link so they can go
online and download them and I can show
this court that I provided them at least
two links to do so
wait a minute
I don't want to waste a bunch more time
on this we've already spent a lot of
time on it I'm just down to the line the
entire the entire trial the entire case
and hearing is a waste of time that's
the little consideration which is
disclosure so they're not
shocked by this disclosure is different
than saying
here's here's here's where all my stuff
is you can dig it so the judge
explaining to the lawyer why it just
doesn't make any sense what they're
doing then they get into an argument
about like an exhibit number
75-year honor it's uh yours your 75r1
no it's there's only one number it's the
Court's number that we're referring to
not mailing line yours is it's 75 and 75
is admitted understood John I say R1 for
their bit
got it very good 75 you're on yeah so
these are the people that apparently are
going to get the Arizona gubernatorial
election overturned so Kerry Lake's
choice of lawyers not particularly good
let's briefly talk about her choice of
experts I'm going to play for you a
brief sample of testimony from Kerry
Lake's supposed expert and this was a
guy who was going to help overturn the
election or something and we already
looked at how her lawyers don't seem
super competent and then now here is an
expert and it all goes bad very very
quickly you know
[Music]
listen to you it would not count it it
would then go to duplication it would be
duplicated
then it would be tabulated is that your
understanding of the elections in
Maricopa County
your technical description is not
possible
I apologize I wasn't attempting to give
a technology I was just saying what
happens
based on your testimony
so you're saying in that scenario that
voter who wanted to vote for Kerry Lake
would never have that vote tabulated is
that your testimony
my testimony is that a shrink to fit
setting would rely at the application
Level which would reside on the EMS
which Mr Garrett just testified since
the print job to the printer therefore
all right you guys understanding this it
can't be accidental as all the employees
that man the EMS are trained
whether it's accidental or inadvertent I
gave the two options sir please allow me
to answer the ask the question I'll
allow you to answer whether it's
accidental or inadvertent if the shrink
to fit 19 inch ballot has to be
duplicated once it's duplicated would it
be tabulated
to your understanding
there are two technical
ways that that image would be there none
of the ways you exist is not even
possible that's not responsive to your
honor so what a waste of time this is
what courts are are now being bogged
down with
um here's another moment where the
witness says that Mike pillow has been I
guess paying for some of his travel
everything about this is crazy
in Missouri Missouri and was your travel
from Alabama to Missouri
paid for by someone other than yourself
yes sir and who paid for that
that would I would assume would be
Michael and Dale
all their travel was arranged he asked
me to speak at the event and I spoke
yeah
so
the expert is funded by pillow and
speaking at Mike pillow events uh
disastrous experts disastrous lawyers
Carrie Lake every day is claiming like
they're getting major legal victories in
in these hearings they are not Katie
Hobbs will be the governor of Arizona
mark my words I'm not a betting man but
that's something I would bet on we have
a voicemail number that number is 2192
David P this caller has a quite frankly
great suggestion about tomorrow's
charity membership Drive take a listen
hello David sir this is Liberty calling
you from Connecticut and I have a
question when you have the new member
drive and the first month
is going to be you're going to match
donations yes to charity and I don't
know the name but I know about the
charity what I would like to suggest is
if you have
either a phone or on on your site an
option for those of us who are already
members right to donate what would be
equivalent to one month membership yeah
for that same purpose to be doubled and
donated we've got it okay if you were
already a member tomorrow when we do the
end of the year charity membership drive
you can get as many memberships as you
want for other people by checking the
box that says this is a gift the payment
will be donated
it will be doubled and the membership
will be given to someone on our
membership waiting list which you can
find at davidpackman.com free membership
we're doing all of it and you can you
can quite literally give the membership
to anyone you want
well it's better if you know how to
spell the person's name which I don't
know that Trump did when he started
reading those names but you can send the
membership to anyone you want or you can
just leave that blank and we'll give it
away we've got like a thousand people
waiting for memberships okay bonus show
today
we're going to talk about Mike Lee's new
obsession with Banning porn
we're going to talk about the permanent
disappearance of daily room cleanings at
hotels since the pandemic good or bad
we'll talk about it and we will talk
about American self-reported mental
health at a new low not good not good
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com get
instant access to the world's famous
thank you
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors Ginger armor is
the daily moisturizing mineral sunscreen
perfect for any skin type chemical
sunscreens can cause health issues
including skin irritation and stinging
eyes but with ginger armors ingredients
from plants and minerals and it being
scent free and rubbing on invisibly in
seconds it's the best get 15 off with
code Pacman using the link below